i have a story today about how sometimes
we can find like a point of agreement
with right wingers
and then very quickly see that point of
agreement
devolve into them having some of the
absolute worst political instincts i can
imagine where
the solutions we imagined to the points
of agreement
couldn't be more different and we've
been covering
the rising unrest in cuba cuba's covid
situation is rapidly devolving
into a public health chaos that we've
not seen throughout the pandemic in cuba
the economy is further collapsing
inflation is starting to explode and
we're not talking about five percent
thanks to more internet access in cuba
the cuban people are now coordinating
and hitting the streets
in protest this is a complicated
situation
in which i as an anti-authoritarian
left-winger oppose the cuban regime
i do not know how anyone calling
themselves progressives could support a
regime
that came to power with fidel castro in
1959
stayed in power he stayed in power for
49
years until 2008 and then handed power
to his brother raul castro that's not
democracy
it's also an authoritarian police state
with total control
over just about every aspect of people
people's lives so
as an anti anti-authoritarian
progressive who's in favor of democracy
uh northern european social democracy
etc i am against that there's no way i
could be
for that and also many cuban americans
oppose that regime
many of them are right wingers but they
oppose the regime often for
different reasons the current mayor of
miami is
cuban-american francis suarez he's the
son of the first cuban-born
mayor of miami the current mayor's
father
javier suarez was also the mayor of
miami previously
and um he went on uh francis suarez that
is
went on fox news yesterday and was
talking about what's going on in cuba
and
somehow he ends up with you know maybe
the u.s
military should bomb cuba
how could that possibly be an action
that would improve what's going on in
cuba if what we want to do is
uh help the cuban people so let's look
at the full clip
and you'll see that along with a long
list of terrible instincts
there's this idea of military action
okay let's listen a repressive
government and a cruel u.s
embargo they deserve policies that
empower them and help them improve their
lives do you think that president biden
looking at this
situation will lift that embargo and do
you think that's what he should
do no i don't think the embargo is is
cool at all and i think that the cuban
people are not asking for a lifting of
the embargo
okay so two two things already first of
all
the cuban embargo you know cruel or not
is completely hypocritical the cuban
embargo is based on the idea that the
united states disagrees with cuba's
system of government
i'm with you i disagree with it as well
i also disagree with saudi arabia's
system of government and yet
we continue that relationship almost
completely unquestioned even by
most of the democratic establishment so
again
if we want to credibly say we want to
help the cuban people
the cuban embargo hasn't forced them to
change their system of government
for uh you know 60 years or whatever the
case is at this point in time 60 60
something or 62 years
um and it's just hurting the cuban
people number two
when suarez says the protests from the
cuban people
aren't against the embargo listen they
may not be
overtly against the embargo but much of
what
is leading cuba to be what it is right
now
is related to that embargo not all of it
part of it is the system of government
in cuba
and i vehemently and vehemently believe
that that has to change
but to say the protests have nothing to
do with the embargo
that that ignores context completely but
let's keep going
on the streets every single day talking
about the failure of the communist
regime
to provide for its people and i don't
understand why
that's so difficult for people to
understand so it can be both
francis we can both say the
authoritarian
police state anti-democratic regime
that's been in place since 1959
is unlikely to be great for the people
of cuba and that's true
and the american embargo also makes it
worth both things can be true then we
get into the military
it has failed for six decades and what
should be being contemplated right now
is a coalition a potential military
action
in cuba similar to what has happened in
both administrations in both republican
and democrat administrations
and republican with bush and panama they
depose noriega
and that country had peace military
action
military action i mean listen it's a
different debate
but one might argue you talk about
military action
if there's a real risk to the united
states or
our interests uh in cuba you know
other than guantanamo bay i don't know
exactly what interests we have
uh there's a national security threat um
cuba
having uh a large population that has
almost nothing
and being oppressed by that regime
military action
come on it is not a national security
threat the likes of which we would be
talking about military action whether
that's bombing
whether that's an assassination campaign
by a
covert arm of the military or whatever
this is uh
just the the the epitome of
i'm against the cuban regime as an
anti-authoritarian
leftist francis suarez is against the
cuban regime
based on the vague idea of being against
communism and we're both against the
regime
but military action that's the last
thing that's on my mind
and it is just another example
of how even when we find points of
agreement
with some of these folks their solutions
are very much the wrong ones and this
has been a big thing with populism i've
said before
one of the dangers of populist rhetoric
and falling for it
is that populist rhetoric from left
wingers and populist rhetoric from right
wingers
sounds very similar and then you get to
the solutions and
man of the people tucker carlson is
saying well we need a solution because
soon black lives matter is going to take
your house and brown people coming in
are the problem
right the immigrants make the country
dirty as he has previously said
and that's the pernicious nature of that
rhetoric so let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter at the pacman
remember that august 16th
is the 16th anniversary of the david
pakman show we are having a huge
membership blowout uh my lawyer
and accountant are beating down the
doors saying sir
don't do it don't do this don't you you
can't do it sir it's going to be too big
of a discount
sure sure exactly but we're doing it on
august 16th
and you can get on our newsletter by
signing up at davidpakman.com
uh hope you'll participate we'll be back
right after this
one of our sponsors today is sheath
underwear
it's the middle of summer that can mean
a lot of
sweating sticking chafing with
traditional underwear
but not with sheath underwear which has
created unique boxer brief designs
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front
keeps everything separate cool dry and
comfortable
even in the hottest time of year
especially when you need it
sheath underwear was invented by an iraq
war veteran who was looking for a
solution
to the problems he was having with
traditional underwear
in the desert heat and he realized that
what he came up with
is perfect for everyday use and that's
where sheath underwear came from
it keeps you dry and comfortable like no
other underwear can
give sheath underwear a try i've had a
great experience with it i know you will
too
you can find the link right underneath
this video and don't forget to use the
promo code pacman
for 20 off